راندي ينضم إلينا الآن من سانت.  بارثس
والآلة الجينية لليخوت ومع ذلك راندي أين
أنت أنا أستمع أنا أحاول الحفاظ
على هذا في الأسفل أنا على رافعة
دفعت هذا على أي حال وهذه هي الطريقة التي
أتسلل بها إلى هذا اليخت ما هو
يجب على الفتاة القيام بها للحصول على يخت في شارع.
بارثس ، حسنًا ، استمع ، أنا أسرع في
الملياردير ، حسنًا
وصحيح تمامًا تخيل أن الأمر يشبه
أننا لم نتدرب عليه أبدًا أو أي شيء ،
لذلك أنا على هذا اليخت وماذا
أهلاً
انظر إلى هذا ، شكرًا ، أنا
لا أنتمي حقًا إلى هنا  لا أخبر أي شخص ولكننا
نعتقد أنه ربما يكون هناك بعض المشاهير على
هذا اليخت مثل ربما ماريا كاري
لست متأكدًا ولكننا على آلة الجينات
ولا أعرف ما إذا كان بإمكانك رؤية
المشهد هنا ولكن هؤلاء هم
ملعب المليارديرات هذا أمر
لا يصدق